Dad?
Yes, son?
This human idea of Christmas shopping does my head in.
I know, son.
It all feels a bit alien, doesn't it, running around panicked?
I thought it was the season to be jolly, but maybe not.
The big man in red seems happy enough.
Everyone else seems terribly stressy, though.
I don't understand why they don't just reserve their presents online with Argos.
As a conundrum, it's up there with Justin Bieber and eggnog.
Eggnog.
Bieber.
To guarantee a great Christmas, Argos it.
Just check and reserve online, and pick up all your presents that same day...
...from over 750 stores.
We believe there's a better way to shop online.
Argos it.
We're walking in the air.